determina si la información dada en la
tabla es un ejemplo de variación directa
inversa o conjunta luego encuentra la
ecuación que representa la relación muy
bien vamos a empezar haciendo un pequeño
repaso de que la variación directa
inversa o conjunta aquí le voy a poner
directa voy a empezar con variación
directa o bien con que las variables xy
ye son directamente proporcionales
en este caso lo que tenemos es que ye yé
la podemos escribir como una constante
multiplicada por x o bien podríamos
dividir entre x ambos lados de esta
igualdad y obtener equivalentemente que
entre x es igual acá o también podríamos
hacerlo al revés podría ser que x x sea
otra constante le voy a poner acá pero
podría ser otra constante multiplicada
por g
y entonces aquí dividiendo entre llenos
quedaría que x entre y es igual acá otra
vez a lo mejor no es la misma acá pero
la idea es esta que al dividir x entre
hoy entre x nos quede una constante y
hay algunas pistas para detectar que
tenemos una variación directa por
ejemplo si tenemos que x aumenta como la
variación es directa también debe de
aumentar que también debe de aumentar en
magnitud si por ejemplo si aquí le pongo
un 2 y luego lo convierto en un 4 pues
lleva a aumentar en magnitud bueno
entonces si x aumenta llega aumenta si x
disminuye ya también disminuye y otra
pista es que si x la multiplicamos
digamos por 3 o sea si de x pasamos a 3x
si multiplicamos por 3 entonces que
también se multiplica por ese mismo
factor que pasaría a 3 y de hecho esto
se puede ver aquí arriba por ejemplo si
la constante fuera uno y tenemos x igual
a 1 y x lo multiplicamos por 3
entonces x pasa de 1 a 3 y que también
pasa de 1
a 3 muy bien entonces estás de acá son
las pistas para determinar una variación
directa
vamos con variación inversa o bien que
las variables sean inversamente
proporcionales y inversa en este caso
ahora la relación que tenemos es que es
igual a una constante pero multiplicada
por el recíproco de x es decir es la
constante multiplicada por uno entre
equis o también multiplicando por equis
de ambos lados lo podemos escribir como
xy xy es igual acá estas dos expresiones
son equivalentes o bien dividiendo aquí
entre ye podemos poner que x x es igual
a cada x 1 entre todas estas vacas son
equivalentes y nos dicen que xy son
inversamente proporcionales y aquí las
pistas son las siguientes
aquí las pistas son que si x aumenta en
magnitud pues saber qué sucedería si x
aumenta en magnitud estamos dividiendo
entre algo más grande entonces aquí toda
esta expresión sería más pequeña por lo
tanto le voy a poner entonces
disminuye vale esto es en cuanto a
tamaños pero siendo un poco más
concretos si x pasa a ser digamos 3x que
sucedería pues si aquí en vez de poner x
ponemos 3 x estamos dividiendo ahora
entre algo tres veces más grande y por
lo tanto esto es algo tres veces más
chiquito es decir que ahora en vez de
multiplicarse por tres se divide entre
tres nos quedaría un tercio un tercio de
y muy bien entonces esta es variación
directa esta es variación inversa
nada más déjame decirte que es variación
conjunta de esta creo que no hemos
platicado tanto y no es tan común en los
cursos de secundaria pero igual es bueno
verla entonces voy a poner aquí
variación conjunta
conjunta y cuando hablamos de variación
conjunta estamos hablando de más de dos
variables de una relación de más de dos
variables por ejemplo cuando decimos que
el área de un rectángulo es igual a su
base por su altura entonces aquí estamos
relacionando tres variables aa le
estamos poniendo directamente
proporcional a b y h
y bueno la pista es ver tres o más
variables ahora como en este ejemplo
solo tenemos a equis y hay pues
claramente no puede ser variación
conjunta entonces podemos descartar este
caso vale ya nada más nos queda
variación directa y variación inversa y
para eso vamos a estudiar qué le sucede
a que cuando x cambia por ejemplo aquí x
paso de 1 a 2 déjame usar otro color
déjame usar otro color este color rosa x
pasa de 1 a 2
entonces x está aumentando que le sucede
allí está disminuyendo 2 pasó de ser 12
a ser 6 aquí está disminuyendo entonces
suena que no va a ser variación directa
mirad incluso más todavía x se
multiplicó por 2 pero ya se dividió
entre
aquí se dividió entre dos entonces no va
a ser no va a hacer variación directa
vale de manera similar si x pasa de 4 a
1 disminuyó y pasa de 3 a 12 aumento
entonces definitivamente no pasa este
fenómeno y bueno como nada más son tres
cosas y descartamos estas dos pues
seguro tiene que ser la tercera verdad
tiene que ser de variación inversa pero
de cualquier forma vamos a verificarlo
vamos a ver si es cierto pues veamos
aquí no sé si x pasa de 2 a 4 x pasa de
2 a 4 entonces está aumentando se está
multiplicando por 2 y aquí la ye pasó de
ser 6 a ser 3 en este caso se está
dividiendo entre 2 y está disminuyendo
entonces y todo pinta a que la relación
es una relación inversa entonces le voy
a poner palomita pero para asegurarnos
así totalmente vamos a hacer la segunda
parte vamos a encontrar la ecuación que
representa la relación entonces como
tenemos en mente que va a ser una una
relación inversa el chiste es ver que el
producto siempre es constante vamos a
ver si es cierto
a ver que nos quedaría voy a poner por
acá x por x porque que nos quedaría en
cada uno de estos casos si x es 1 y es
12 el producto es 12 2 por 6 también es
12 3 por 4 también es 12 y finalmente 4
por 3 también es 12 guau qué suerte
entonces el producto de las dos siempre
es igual a 12 es decir tenemos xy x por
james es igual a 12 y por lo tanto esta
es la ecuación que representa a la
relación y ahora sí podemos verificar
que en efecto es un ejemplo de relación
en la cual las variables están
inversamente proporcionales o
inversamente relacionadas vale el
producto es constante bueno